duras et je peux vous le dire maintenant
voilà je vous dis noram donc nous
rejoindra il fera une rubrique
entrées/sorties noam c'est ce jeune
homme qui a fait le buzz pendant le
confinement et qu'ils faisaient question
pour un balcon ah oui il est excellent
et je vais vous donner aussi le nom d'un
nouveau chroniqueur alors je vous le dis
c'est peut-être pas un mot qui va vous
parler mais c'est quelqu'un que je veux
depuis plusieurs années c'est un petit
peu comme à l'époque et raymond le sait
j'avais camille combal dans mon oeil
depuis quelques années je suivais sur w9
il garçon qui va arriver lui aussi je le
suis depuis plusieurs années en plus un
pote va nous rejoindre je vous le dis
c'est thomas villechaize thomas mich est
question des mines sa mort [ __ ] c'est un
très très bon gars qui nous fera tous
les jours une rubrique entrées/sorties
enfin trois fois par semaine et qui est
en train de travailler que les équipes
qui est excellent je préfère vous le
dire moi ah bah oui on vous l'apprenait
pas souvent au bureau en ce moment il
travaille
c'est un beau gosse en plus à rien
d'avoir un bébé heureusement mais
malheureusement vient d'avoir un bébé
pour les filles voilà je fais mais voilà
c'est un amour de mecs et c'est surtout
un pote et voilà et je suis content
d'avoir un pote avec nova tient quand
même à vous annoncer beaucoup de choses
hein cyril alors la tap va pas
énormément changé d'avis parce que je
veux vraiment que les gens retrouvent
leurs repères les gens qu'ils aiment
bien voilà donc c'est sûr mais au niveau
voilà y aura deux nouvelles rubriques
déjà c'est déjà énorme
et peut-être bouder voilà tous les jours
avec nous donc ça c'est déjà
exceptionnel et il y aura un ou deux
autres noms nouveau mais pas plus
voilà en tout cas autour de la capture à
1 ou 2 notre nom nouveau mais pas plus
que ce que j'aurais conservé l'ossature
un voile alors c'est comme ça vient
c'est est ce que ça vous plaît alors
michel et pouvait les voir ça peut être
une photo de thomas on va essayer de
vous la sorte thomas travers la tomate a
passé une belle photo ces taux bas très
bien voilà il est beau il est beau
arrêté mais c'est un pote mais très bon
voilà ils excellent auquel il est beau
très beau
franchement une entrée et une sortie
j'aurais pas lui mais qui reste tout
il est en bronze et comme ça tout le
temps je souhaite tout en faisant il est
saint raphaël comme vous j'adore voilà
exactement donc voilà donc il est
souvent fait donc je vous le dis que
sophie on aura des soldats des choses à
se raconter vaches pour moi là-bas je
perds semaine c'est vraiment il aime
bien le direct il est très drôle il
adule a beaucoup d'humour match mais
j'aime bien ça trop cru bernard et a une
bonne tête mais je suis hélas il est
illettré rien le voilà et je n'embrasse
forme on thomas voilà chef et je vais
même pas dit non plus que j'ai il
annoncé aujourd'hui
donc il va voir plein de jolis mais ça
et je veux dire un petit truc c'est
qu'il restera sur bin sport parce qu'il
est sur bin sport et nos amis de binh
sport une fois de plus ils ont été d'un
fair-play absolue encore mon flore ouzou
le patron de bobines qui m'a dit y'a
aucun souci tu peux prendre un thomas et
continuera à commenter le handball bien
sûr sur bin parce que le handball c'est
un sport qu'on adore et thomas c voilà
c'est sa passion donc il fera ça et il
fera également tpm paie tous les jours
donc je vous le dis il ya énormément de
nouveautés et il nous reste très peu
d'émissions maintenant parce qu'on
arrête le 18 juin
parce que si on fait un pincement aucun
surtout que la saison était cette année
parce que le confinement on était là
mais en même temps c'était on n'était
pas physiquement les uns avec les autres
donc y avait pas là l'ambiance des loges
de c'est tout ce qui se passe entre nous
quoi donc
et c'est une sorte de monde vous savez
entre nous je trouve que c'est le temps
qui sont fuis qu'ils sont c'est une
sorte de saison un peu mi figue mi
raisin voyez on dirait on dirait on
dirait une vivaldi mal à exactement
c'est encore une année exceptionnelle
cirque chaque année on a l'impression
qu'on a c'est le vide en effet et chaque
année cette année on fera une première
mondiale l'émission sur zoom on dirait
deux comme ça tous les jours ou presque
quatre heures pendant presque un mois
deux mois on a fait la croatie boudissa
mais jamais été fait chaque année on à
vendre des trucs
celui ci une aventure folle on n'imagine
jamais moi j'ai juste 3 d'être à la
dernière pour pouvoir faire le deuil de
cette année parce que c'est vrai que ça
a été difficile pour nous comment ça
s'est passé vers la fin comme dit comme
dit valérie on a eu du mal à mais on
s'est appelé mais bon c'était pas
physique et puis même là c'est encore
difficile
donc j'espère vraiment qu'on va avoir
une super émission pour pouvoir clôturer
cette année
est ce que je voulais dire aussi c'est
que c'est important d'avoir des
nouvelles personnes qui sont sympas
comme vous dites ce serait cool qui
sombra qui soit vraiment to school parce
que nous c'est important comme on skie
vraiment pour
vrai on a vraiment besoin de nouvelles
personnes qui m'a qui sont de bons
esprits bernard oui parce que cette
pandémie
pendant deux mois qui a été assez
redoutable c'est vrai que du coup ça a
créé un manque et donc se moquant
laissait un peu de le rattraper vite
fait en tout cas avec les
téléspectateurs avec vous mais c'est
spécial
il manque quand même quelque chose de
faite c'est spécial c'était moi je vais
vous dire ce qui me manque
franchement je le dis aux techniques et
puis voir les gens dont public allait
leur part lyrique et avec quoi faire le
show pour eux aussi au plateau et ça ça
me manque énormément et bien sûr
j'espère qu'à la rentrée on va pouvoir
retrouver sa